I know that I've said this before Pat
that the most embarrassing and ignorant
thing that Trump has done on the
national stage just happened and then a
week goes by and then once again I say
okay now Trump has done the most
embarrassing thing and usually it's true
because we think we've hit the top or
sometimes it's rock bottom and then he
does some something worse he might undo
outdo himself in the future indefinitely
and that is where we are today
there's a stunning report in france's
newspaper Lamond which alleges that
donald trump did two mind-blowing things
in april so in April Donald Trump met
with the leaders of Lithuania Estonia
and Latvia now if you hear those three
countries and think oh there's something
about those three countries as a group
yes they're called the Baltic states
these are three countries in Northern
Europe that are now independent
countries on the Baltic Sea previously
subject to USSR rule I guess we could
call it I was in one of those countries
over the summer Estonia absolutely
beautiful place fantastic people amazing
architecture culture great food those
three countries are the Baltic countries
Donald Trump confuse them in front of
their leaders with the Balkans
now the Balkans are not the Baltic
countries the Balkans are in a different
part of Europe about a thousand miles
away
they include Albania Bulgaria Bosnia and
Herzegovina Kosovo Macedonia Montenegro
they ended up in their current state
after the early 90s breakup of
Yugoslavia and geographically you could
say that the the the Peninsula the
Balkan Peninsula includes pieces of some
other countries as well Donald Trump
confused the Baltics and the Balkans and
then he said something that made
absolutely no sense and according to
this report in Newsweek the leaders of
the three Baltic states were just sort
of confused looking around like what the
hell is this guy talking about and then
they realized that
Trump thinks that they are from the
Balkans not the Baltics and what Trump
said was that they are responsible for
starting wars that led to the breakup of
Yugoslavia
in 1991 can you imagine you are the
president of Estonia or Latvia you know
whichever one of these countries you are
you've come out of the USSR you've
rebuilt the country your country is a
sort of beacon of success in a region
that has had many political and economic
problems in Estonia one of the most
technologically advanced democracies in
the world you get invited to the White
House Wow President of the United States
you fly halfway around the world and the
president says to you you did a bad
thing when you started that war that
broke up Yugoslavia and then you realize
the guy has no idea where you're from an
absolute and total embarrassment and Pat
this is what you get when you combine
ignorant and anti intellectualism
with a political movement that sees that
as a virtue and enshrines ignorant anti
intellectuals as leaders you get the
leaders of Estonia Latvia and Lithuania
saying what the hell is the president
talking about right now and let's
remember it's been the u.s. that has
been starting the wars in recent memory
namely the war in Iraq but yeah Trump
just is not very good with geography he
referred to Namibia the country in
Africa as nambia he doesn't understand
the differences between the United
Kingdom and Great Britain and England he
thinks those things are interchangeable
they're all the same yeah you should
just study up I think that's what it
comes down to the right loves to slam
the left for language policing but they
do their own language policing and then
the right likes to slam the left for
identity politics but then you realize
wait a second the entire Trump n't the
alt-right these are identity movements
and they happen to be horrible identity
movements and then the right likes to
slam the left for virtue signaling which
they do just as much if not more of
except with horrible virtues like those
of
dogmatic religious belief and
anti-education ideas they always defend
this stuff the same way listen Trump's
not a lifelong politician he can't know
everything he's making the right
decisions and that's what actually
matters if you're president you get held
to the same standards as other
presidents and misstating the wars that
other countries have started not knowing
what country's leaders you're even
meeting with these aren't like niche
micro criticisms this is basic stuff
that's truly pathetic and it's not
making America great again this is an
absolute and total embarrassment